[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let me start there with mike tarico who
joins us
from augusta we've been talking about
conforto leans in
on the pitch what did you make of that
mike
so i always wondered when i did the nba
games and
they i thought did a good job of using
replay i always thought
when you go to replay and you see that
you screwed up a call how do you feel
right and that's exactly the case and i
i just saw the clip of it on social
media so i didn't see the entirety of it
uh but what keith hernandez and ron
darling and gary cohen were saying
is exactly right if you can go to replay
get it right that's what we all want at
the end of the day
it seems as though replay in every sport
has gotten so involved
that it's lost any common sense ability
to be applied
and there you say yeah okay we're not
supposed to look at that but you know
what
he moves his elbow in to strike
strikeout let's move on
common sense it would be nice if we
could apply some common sense to stuff
a little bit more these days but i was
also wondering
that the the umpire can only do so much
because
of what the rule is that they can't they
can't rule on intent
that they know they they made the wrong
call because he did lean in but
they don't have the authority to be able
to overturn that
that's that's the problem once and
here's where i think you can
maybe use this a little bit better
because
it's not the official right there
looking at the replay making the
decision
it's going back to the global
headquarters right it's going back to
mlb
mlb can make that decision you're right
there so it
expand it let's add some elasticity to
the powers of replay
the league office can say okay i know we
didn't have line
73 addendum b to replay when the guy
puts his armor in the strike zone
but let's make sense of this and this is
the right thing to do and you know what
at the end of the day the mets may have
said
it doesn't go with line 73 note b but
it's the right thing because
you could see his post game uh sound
bite was pretty good
he totally looked like the uh the canary
he ate the canary there he's just kind
of
yeah yeah i kind of leaned in a little
bit but do you respect him for doing
that
yes a thousand percent okay for saying
it or for doing it
no for doing it for doing it i i hate
the fact that the guys with that armor
and we talked to this with bonds right
years ago
it's different you can crowd the plate
in a different way than guys used to
i don't like all that body armor for
batters but that ship has long sail
i remember talking to mike tarico
joining us from augusta
uh the course played tough intentionally
yesterday i i think that there's
uh two things it's not really the
20 under par was november we're not
going to let that happen again
uh i think the u.s opened for a long
time had
lived with we've got to get a score
somewhere around even par
i don't think that's been the case with
the masters that you've been here so
many times
think about sundays they want those
eagle opportunities and those
roars that's what's made the masters
special so they're not allergic to great
scoring
i do think that there's been a desire
over the years
to keep the distance in check and look
at fast and firm
and what it did to the guys who hit it a
long way
there were struggles for a lot of them
on day one so i think
the defense is remaining of course
especially this one
to keep it relevant and we're about
again
it felt fair justin rose had an 11 hole
stretch where he went nine under
so it was not us open impossible
it was playable for great scores
and a great day and justin rose had 11
great holes
how great is deshambo for tv
i think he's great for the sport which
in turn is great for tv
so so i want to go back to bay hill
the arnold palmer tournament and the six
hole where he's trying to drive it over
the water 340 yards right
that scene of people with their cameras
videotaping it and the guy was like 560
for a lady i don't know who it was but
that scene where you get all the arms it
looked like a rock concert right
and the shaft was like yeah i did it
right
i think that's great so so i thought
we talked about this a lot when we were
working together when tiger
showed up on the scene we all thought it
would bring minorities to the game
i think what it did was bring athletes
to the game and it brought casual golf
fans to the tv dan
i think because anytime tiger got over a
shot he might do something
that you'll talk about for a long time
like nobody was saying i've got to watch
the canadian open because when tiger
gets to the bunker
he may hit this six shot out of a bunker
over water and landed this close right
the shadow is the same kind of thing
like he's spraying it all over augusta
but i can't wait to watch where is he
going to drive it
on 13 is he going to take it over the
trees on the left is he going to go down
where the
patrons are on 14 so i think that
element is
sensational for the sport there's a
curiosity but it's got to be
have a payoff it feels like with tiger
you were watching something that was
going to
inevitably have a payoff where he was
going to win
deshambo is a curiosity to me until he
you know he starts winning on a
consistent basis where he's you know
kepca you know brooks capco is a better
golfer than duchambeau
but december is more of a curiosity here
but but dechambeau did win a u.s open
had a really tough course in wingfoot
right so
so i think that plus backed up with wind
look he's won arnold's tournament he's
won jack's tournament at the memorial
he won the us amateur so it's not as
though it's all the circus show
these played great golf difficult golf
courses tough events to win
so i i think there's a lot of curiosity
but i do think there's enough there that
it's not just a sideshow
i think it's really effective dan i i
really i spent some time with him
in the fall i i think he's as
fascinating an athlete not just a golfer
an athlete
as we have in sports because of his
approach and you talk to him and
it seems like a little mad scientist but
he's thought it all out and he's
processed it he's got a plan
and i just like that it's unique and
he's willing to be the salmon he's
willing to swim upstream
and do this in a different way well i
liken him to elon musk
i i think that there's something about
his approach where you go
i don't know you know but we've seen
elon musk as a
a billionaire and has proven everybody
wrong and maybe duchambeau does that and
you bring up valid points with
you know he did win at wingfoot which is
a tough tough course to win on
uh were you guys hanging out in the
weight room were you spotting him
while he was lifting weights uh protein
shakes i was only protein shakes for him
on a regular basis i i'm the shake man
yeah
no just just chance to interview him and
talk to him and just spend a little more
time
than just hey a quick hello on the range
and it was uh it was fascinating to see
how much he's thought about things
see i think of you as kind of a deshambo
and elon musk
go against the grain do things that
others are not expecting you know become
a billionaire
i i think you fit that category as well
maybe you should connect more with
bryson
thank you thank you i didn't want to say
it i'm glad that you said it
uh before i let you go i've been to
augusta
a few times but if somebody has never
been there
like the first thing that is going to
wow them is what
how beautiful it is how there's not a
piece of trash or a weed growing there's
nothing wrong with anything
you see and then there was someone here
a co-worker of mine i took him down
to the ninth fairway the crosswalk at
nine because you've seen it
many many many times on tv but until you
go across that crosswalk and you're
about 20 yards ahead of where the
players
hit their second shot and you look up
and all you can see is the front lobe of
the green
that doesn't hold any shots that's the
one that just sticks with people that
while the elevation changes are out of
this world
tv cannot and does not do it justice
when when they see that usually the the
impression is
wow i never realized that and those
things stick out i think more than
anything else
yeah i i think it's great uh when you go
there
in a sensory overload but the one thing
that stood out was when you walk that
course
that's a workout like you know you you
give get the feeling well it's in
augusta georgia it's got to be flat
there is so much elevation there that
was the biggest uh surprise
like that shot on 18 going up the hill
like you're going up
you're going up a mountain there it
feels like at times we had a player in
the augusta national women's diameter
she was in the bunker she jumped twice
and her caddy who's her coach at
university of houston said aim for the
top
of the tv tower and she's like i can't
see the top
of the tv tower it gives you when you
were here in the 90s doing sportscenter
stuff
were you here with uh jim colbert as one
of your animals yes
yes i remember that gosh i remember that
yes
he would do the uh whatever that was
like you know he would
be shooting he'd be shooting a gun or
saying yeah
and he'd do that when he made it when he
used to make a birdie on the channel
yeah
his name came up randomly when i was
driving down washington road
past where you guys used to do the show
across from augusta national
yeah i think it was called the um the
double eagle club
double eagle it's still there oh it is
yeah oh
gosh yeah i i don't know if i knew what
i was doing back then but you know i got
to see i was there when faldo
came back and beat norman and uh rick
riley had the famous quote because i
talked to him on saturday and i said
what do you think is going to happen he
said greg norman always finds the banana
peel
i'll never forget that and then years
later got a chance to sit down with
norman and
we revisited that that day and what it
meant to him
and how it impacted him and uh you know
he and he was a professional in looking
back on it
he said look i beat myself nick didn't
beat me i beat myself
but hey i'm the one that hits the hit
the shots he
he was brutally honest with himself and
that's what i love about this sport like
you will find guys who will just kind of
pour out their emotions
and let you know exactly you know how
this felt like jordan spieth when he
lost
the masters at 12 or rory when he goes
sideways you get into that press tent
and it just feels like it's a
confessional for a lot of these guys
well dan that's why i've loved my
association with golf and this is now 24
years
since i started covering golf on a
regular basis
what i love is that it's you and your
score in a perpetuity there's no
offensive coordinator to blame for a bad
play call
you can't say the offensive line was
banged up and not protecting me
uh it's just you you know your caddy may
hand you a club but you can always say
no
so that's what i love about their
honesty it's refreshing calling
rules and fractions on yourself it is a
great game
you have to remind yourself of that
sometimes when you try when you try to
play it like these guys do
uh and you realize how good even the
lower guys in the tour really are
good to talk to you mike as always have
fun today we appreciate your time
safe travels same here mr bud look
forward to you soon
it's mike trurico he'll be uh working
today with the golf coverage
and uh keeping an eye on the leaderboard
there